emmanuel macron a été réélu président de
la république voulait peut-être suivi
avec moi sur ma chaîne fritsch puisque
vous étiez très nombreux mais alors que
faut-il retenir les scores les réactions
l'abstention ou encore le vote des
jeunes et les manifestations ce dimanche
soir voici donc ce qu'il faut retenir en
une vidéo sachant que évidemment on
prendra le temps de voir les réactions
les conséquences dans les prochains
jours sur cette chaîne youtube mais
aussi sur notre compte instagram hugo
décrypte du coup évidemment n'hésitez
pas à vous abonner je ne sais pas encore
le cas et on commence donc avec les
résultats c'est donc emmanuel macron qui
a été réélu président de la république
avec 58 5% des voix selon les dernières
estimations des différents instituts de
sondage au moment où je tourne ça va par
ailleurs se préciser dans les prochaines
heures marine le pen la candidate du
rassemblement national a récolté donc
environ 41 5% des voix en aura a priori
les résultats définitifs dans la journée
de lundi du coup évidemment je vous
tiendrai au courant le score est donc
plus serré qu'en 2017 puisqu'en 2007
c'est bien emmanuel macron n'avait pas
récolté 58 % des voix mais 66% des voix
à ce moment là et d'ailleurs derrière
ces pourcentages c'est intéressant de
noter l'évolution du vote entre 2017 et
2022 en effet ce week end le candidat de
la république en marche a récolté 17
millions de voix c'est beaucoup mais
c'est trois points 7,5 millions de voix
de moins qu'en 2017 et à linverse même
si jamais elle ne remporte pas à cette
élection marine le pen progresse c'est
d'ailleurs la première fois que le
rassemblement national fait un tel score
au second tour de l'élection
présidentielle et elle a récolté 12
millions de voix soit 1 5 million de
voix de plus qu'en 2007 alors ça c'est
donc pour les résultats qui seront
confirmées dans les prochaines heures et
maintenant voyons pour les réactions et
on commence avec emmanuel macron qui
s'est exprimé depuis le champ de mars à
paris donc sous la tour eiffel alors il
arrivait en marchant main dans la main
avec sa femme brigitte macron mais aussi
entouré d'enfants et d'adolescents une
mise en scène assez particulière sachant
que en 2017 déjà et bien il y avait une
autre mise en scène qui avait fait
beaucoup parler puisque il était venu
pour célébrer sa victoire au louvre en
marchant tout seul et d'ailleurs comment
2017 il a choisi d'arriver avec l' ode à
la joie l'hymne donc officiel de l'union
européenne
après ça il s'est donc exprimé pendant
une dizaine de minutes environ de ce
qu'il veut faire pour les cinq
prochaines années en affirmant être je
cite le président de tous mais en étant
aussi conscient que beaucoup n'ont pas
voté pour lui par choix mais plutôt pour
faire barrage à marine le pen voici donc
les moments à retenir au moins d'une
minute de son discours je sais aussi
que nombre de nos compatriotes ont voté
ce jour pour moi non pour soutenir les
idées que je porte mais pour faire
barrage à celle de l'extrême droite je
pense enfin à ceux qui ont voté pour
madame le pen dont je sais la déception
ce soir non
ainsi toutes les personnes
depuis le début je vous ai demandé de ne
jamais sifflé je ne suis plus le
candidat d'un camp
mais le président de toutes et tous les
années à venir à coup sûr
ne seront pas tranquilles
mais elles seront historiques et
ensemble nous aurons à les écrire pour
nos générations
[Applaudissements]
passons maintenant au discours de marine
le pen qui a salué une éclatante
victoire selon elle de son camp malgré
sa défaite avec donc ce progrès en terme
de score que je viens d'évoquer alors on
a très clairement fait comprendre
qu'elle n'arrêterait pas la politique et
à parler d'ailleurs dès maintenant des
élections législatives voici là aussi un
extrait avec plus de 43% des voix le
résultat de ce soir présente en lui même
une éclatante victoire
emmanuel macron ne fera rien pour
réparer les fractures qui divise notre
pays et font souffrir nos compatriotes
pour éviter cet accaparement des
pouvoirs par quelques-uns plus que
jamais je poursuivrai mon engagement
pour la france et les français
la persévérance et la fiction que vous
me connaissez
je le redis jamais je n'abandonnerai les
princes est vive la république
jean luc mélenchon le candidat de la
france est soumise arriver donc
troisième juste derrière marine le pen
au premier tour de la présidentielle a
également pris la parole ce soir alors
il a déclaré que la défaite de marine le
pen était une bonne nouvelle mais elle a
aussi fortement critiqué la politique d'
emmanuel macron et à appeler en fait à
une mobilisation massive pour les
élections législatives dans le but
d'avoir justement ce que l'on appelle
une cohabitation donc une majorité de
députés de gauche pour qu'ils soient
ensuite nommé premier ministre puisque
c'est la conséquence le pré ministre
doit être issu et bien de la majorité
des députés à l'assemblée nationale
les urnes ont tranché madame le pen est
battu
la france a refusé clairement de lui
confier son avenir et c'est une très
bonne nouvelle
pour l'unité de notre peuple
à présent monsieur macron est le plus
mal élu des présidents de la vème
république le 12 et 19 juin en vous
appelant à mes lire comme premier
ministre je vous appelle en vérité à
faire vivre un nouvel avenir en commun
pour notre peuple voilà donc pour les
trois candidats arrivés largement devant
au premier tour quand aux autres
candidats va pas tous les passés en
revue mais ils ont été nombreux à avoir
réagi eric zemmour notamment qui arrivé
quatrième donc après les trois premiers
que je viens de citer ici avec 7% des
voix il a fait part de sa déception il a
appelé à une union avec bien son parti
mais aussi le rassemblement national ou
encore et bien le parti debout la france
de nicolas dupont aignan et certains
élus des républicains on voit donc que
pour quasiment tous les partis
politiques c'est bien de cette élection
à l'initiative qui a un enjeu majeur
aujourd'hui autre élément par ailleurs a
noté plusieurs manifestations ont eu
lieu juste après l annonce des résultats
sur la place de la république par
exemple à paris mais aussi dans d'autres
villes 16 comme rennes toulouse ou
encore marseille ces manifestations ont
surtout été lancée par des mouvements
d'extrême gauche ou encore des
mouvements anti fascistes des gilet
jaune était aussi présent et c'est en
général les personnes qui s'opposaient à
marine le pen mais aussi à emmanuel
macron alors certaines de ces
manifestations s'était faite de façon
assez spontané donc il ya eu aussi bien
des débordements alors que les forces de
l'ordre tentaient de faire partir les
manifestants les différents lieux de
rassemblement je voulais aussi donc
aujourd'hui vous faire un petit point
sur le vote des jeunes comme pour le
premier tour alors là ça se base sur des
sondages et sur des premières
estimations qui resteront donc à affiner
dans les prochains jours alors selon un
sondage de l'institut ipsos sopra steria
émules mâcon est arrivé en tête chez les
18 24 ans avec 61% des voix mais chez
les 25-34 ans c'est beaucoup plus serrée
est venu macron arrive avec 51% des voix
contre 49% pour marine le pen sachant
que tout ça va forcément se préciser
dans les prochains jours c'est
intéressant aussi de noter que chez les
personnes âgées et plus particulièrement
chez les 70 ans et plus une île macron
arrive largement en tête avec 71 % des
voix en fait la seule tranche d'âge
selon les premiers sondages chez
lesquels marine le pen arrive en tête
c'est chez les 50-59 ans avec 51% des
voix rhin moi aussi qui me semble
important à mentionner concernant le
taux d'abstention donc le pourcentage de
personnes inscrites sur les listes
électorales mais qui ne sont pas allés
voter et bien cette année il est estimé
à 29 % pour ce scrutin contre 25 4 %
d'abstention en 2017 au second tour là
aussi selon les premiers chiffres d'ifop
fiducial pour tf1 lci c'est donc des
chiffres qui seront précisées dans les
prochaines heures mais c'est le taux
d'abstention le plus important depuis
l'élection de 1969 on aura l'occasion
donc de revenir là dessus dans les
prochains jours ce que forcément ça pose
question enfin pour terminer on notera
que le nombre de votes blancs et de
votes nuls est estimé à 6 4% de
l'ensemble des votes donc votre
blanc-seing votes blancs et un vote nul
c'est un vote qui est jugée invalide par
exemple si quelqu'un a écrit sur son
bulletin c'est donc ce qu'indiquent les
premiers chiffres d lab et d'harris
interactive
là aussi vous l'aurez compris ce sera
précisée dans les prochaines heures
sachant que en france aujourd'hui les
votes blancs sont décomptés c'est pour
ça que là on a on va avoir des chiffres
officiels ministère de l'intérieur mais
ils ne sont pas pris en compte en gros
ce que ça veut dire c'est que si 55% des
gens votent blanc eh bien ça ne change
rien et je serai bien donc le candidat
arrivé en tête au second tour qui serait
il eu en france voilà donc pour ce
premier débrief et ce qu'on sait donc ce
soir dans la nuit de dimanche à lundi ça
me semblait assez essentiel de vous
faire cette vidéo même si jamais elle
est publiée très tard dans la nuit on va
prendre le temps évidemment d'analyser
tout ça dans les prochains jours on va
évidemment aussi parlé des élections
législatives qui se dérouleront au mois
de juin pour suivre tout ça en tout cas
dans les prochains jours ça se passe sur
cette chaîne youtube n'hésitez pas à
vous abonner au c'est sur notre chaîne
youtube des actes du jour là aussi je me
faisais pas encore abonné je vous mets
le lien directement en descriptions et
aussi notamment sur notre compte
instagram je tiens en tout cas à vous
remercier parce que vous avez été très
très nombreux à suivre cette élection
présidentielle avec nous avec les
décryptages des programmes avec les
interviews de la quasi totalité des
candidats à l'élection présidentielle
merci encore pour votre confiance je le
dis à chaque fois j'en suis bien
conscient mais voilà merci vraiment pour
votre soutien et votre confiance
évidemment parlera donc de la suite dans
les prochains jours les initiatives les
changements au sein du gouvernement on
va voir tout ça d'ici là prenez cendres
vous proposons nos proches et on se dit
à très vite pour une nouvelle vidéo